men don't expect you to be perfect no we
do not expect women to fit one specific
mold most women out there can find male
suitors because we are actually far more
forgiving of female body types and all
their splendorous forms alright just a
guest so question of the day since
there's not a lot going on outside of
Trump Ukraine and the Kurds and Turkey
we don't have enough info on that yet so
we always try to wait yeah this is
something that's just been but let me
ask you do you told him related do you
buy into the whole idea of the
unrealistic female body image standard
and that we live in an unfair society
because you hear about this so much I
feel as though everyone rolls their eyes
when they hear a woman going into you
know it's really hard for a woman today
in the industry go oh okay so let me
yeah i'm not making a lot of sense let
me let me kind of that's a rough woman
set this up really quick before we go to
a clip to accept the idea of this double
standard is established by patriarchy
the idea of an unrealistic female body
standard in a cruel society you have to
accept three premises okay one there's a
universally accepted unrealistic body
standards set for women two that's
enforced upon women by men and three
that this standard is exclusively or
unfairly applied toward women none of
those are true I think that's why all of
us are sick with the fat pride and
everyone talking about how women are
held to some unrealistic standard but
lest you take my word for it here are
some other people making these arguments
the double age of the patriarchy is
basically just a woman who perhaps
unknowingly is still putting the
patriarchal narrative out into the world
but you are extensions for doesn't make
us feel good you're selling us an ideal
of a body shape it's a double standard
because you know there are men with
really beautiful women that don't have
great bodies and and yet nobody's saying
anything about that I think it hits a
little too close to home with Porsha del
Rossi I think this is not exclusive to
you women and I want to say here's the
silver lining and this is why we get
really pissed off when we talk about fat
pride men don't expect you to be perfect
no we do not expect women to fit
one specific mold we do not expect you
to be a size zero the beauty is women if
you're married your husband finds you
attractive or your boyfriend finds you
attractive he wants to see you naked
most women out there can find male
suitors because we are actually far more
forgiving of female body types and all
their splendorous forms then women are
and I think women you're harder on men
then men are on women so a couple of
things first off it's important to
understand there is an ideal there's a
beauty standard that's set when I go
you're watching a film we're admiring
someone's beauty of course that is
something that actually exists it
doesn't mean that we expect everybody to
look that way and there wasn't a secret
meeting behind women's back where we
said hey you know we don't even like
boobs and butts we're just gonna throw
this out there yeah to throw them for a
loop so there was something recent look
this is every time some advertisement
comes out yeah well there's a beautiful
person the social justice works get
upset about I think this was remember
this we have the set it was a protein
shake I think that sparked outrage in
London I don't know if you're ashamed of
your body then that's your own thing and
some of you should be ashamed of your
body look look at their advertisements
for men okay right here there you go
look yeah I'm one one green smoothie
away from that oh just a little workout
we're just over that I think the reason
and this creates more of a divides this
divide and conquer between men and women
where women think that men expect
something from them that they don't and
then women throughout this idea that oh
you know what it's okay for men to be
fat they're not held to these standards
look and they start naming comedians
like John Belushi not Jim Belushi that's
just an essence there's a bridge too far
no one likes that nobody according to
Jim I've seen make-a-wish Foundation
videos that are funnier than according
to Joe but let's look at the famous fat
guys out there you look at Chris Farley
look at these commands no one was using
the advertised weight loss shakes no
they weren't valued for their looks they
were valued for their contributions to
comedy think about this for a second
Cary Grant Gregory Peck up to Hugh
Jackman none of them were ever fat guys
no none of them this idea that there's
no standard set for men or that
in cannot feel uncomfortable in their
own skin this is a lie and it's also why
these three premises are important has
it been enforced upon women by men it is
applied exclusively to women I say no no
I don't I don't think so and it's it's
weird to say to like that like you said
that there's some thing that we got
together and decided this is what beauty
is
it's symmetry a lot of times that we see
and that can come in all kinds of shapes
and sizes as long as it's symmetrical
they've done Studies on this well I also
think it's it's far harder for a man to
attain the standards that you would see
in magazines while we're talking oh yeah
this yeah let's do it right here here's
a cover of Cosmo the same month as a
cover of men's self is more attainable
right I get it men don't necessarily
feel pressure we don't look at that and
Greg oh my gosh can you believe no we
look at him going oh okay well that guy
did something likely took diuretics yeah
and and anabolic steroids and he was in
a hot Epsom salt bath with you hunter
green dehydrating himself she just had
to do yoga for a few months all men
expect of you women all men expect is
for you to not be wildly unhealthy yes
that's it and here's something else to
push this idea of body positivity now
we've gone so far that we are actually
encouraging people to be unhealthy Cosmo
decided to reverse course because that
woman of course was offensive of course
and unattainable no woman in their net
in the natural realm could look like
that
so we now put tests holiday on the cover
I think we have no idea yeah there you
go show me a men's magazine that
glorifies a fat guy like you won't find
it yeah no one is trying to find the guy
who bathes in a pig trough and put him
on the cover of Men's Journal do they
charge more for tattoos if your body is
bigger I'm an area to cover
here's your study to Tibet this up so if
12,000 people show that stats for both
men and women they're the same but a
quarter felt very - extremely satisfied
with their appearances regardless of
gender and and this is something else -
this idea that it's dictated by men and
this is why I want this I come bearing
you tidings of great joy
we don't expect this from you and this
is why men roll their eyes and say oh my
gosh have a victim complicit you just
don't understand no we don't expect you
to look like Kate Upton we think she's
pretty but when you feel these
unrealistic standards of beauty being
applied to you or you feel as though you
have to live up to them then all of a
sudden as you heard that first lady in
the in the Rouge and lipstick and the
extensions and everything she apparently
hates ya sexual flushing which occurs
like okay well that's probably true
smart guy but let me ask you this here
are the people were talking about
something different the entertainment
industry and the fashion industry really
that's really more of a byproduct of
consumerist culture right where they're
trying to sell you beauty products well
do I really think it's straight and
straight men are in charge at the
patriarchy let's go to the tale of the
tape it really is survival of the
fittest okay OMG yeah ruffled shrug and
vinyl busy and tacky real 80s
II kind of like Knott's landing
oh now just let's just imagine for a
moment that a straight guy behaved that
way with women
no listen your bone to pick is with
women who run the fashion and they're
gay male counterparts okay then we have
a section from Houston Press that a
majority of fashion magazines they have
female editorial staff because hashtag
all women female empowerment they're the
ones who want you to look real thin this
is something people need to understand
as well if you look at women's magazines
things like Cosmo or things like what
are other women's magazines Vanity Fair
I have no I know there any fairs I I
don't like no yeah what are the women's
where you look at the fashion runway
models I guess they're the ones you look
at there's something from a Spielberg
film those are marketed toward women
right
what's marketed toward men as far as
magazines no that wouldn't maybe like
playboy or or FHM the women are curvier
the women are larger this is what men
find more attractive the glorification
of super tall super thin ultra skinny
unrealistic women and by the way some
women looked that way let's not condemn
that I want them to develop an eating
disorder but that idea so that's the
only way to be a true
is pushed by none other than your
sisters and I guess they're gay male
sisters allies out there do not blame me
said the entire row of straight men we
want to see you naked no matter what
notification Bell join my club levels
kind of become such Mugler because
YouTube will probably shut this down
because everything is offensive I think
something else that we need to look at
is is this something that is applied
only to women as it turns out the bar is
set higher for men so let's look at this
if you look at dating apps a lot of
people don't realize this women actually
are far more harsh in rating men's
appearances which surprised me because I
will I will concede that men are more
visually stimulated right right men like
looking at attractive women we just tend
to see almost all women as attractive
like hey hey there's a naked woman what
do you think she looks good hey there's
another naked woman who's an entirely
different size and stature what do you
think yeah it looks good I like that too
but women as opposed to men who rate on
a bell curve women rate over 80% of men
as being below average attractiveness
not these dating apps so here's the
thing even though many of you out there
women you may you may just look like
this you may look like an average woman
right right
most men still see this okay now that
being said for most men you may look
like this you may look like an average
man most women see this this is what
they're seeing yeah oh we're not to talk
about magazine covers let me just just
just try to ride some understanding
you're just bridging the gender gap
sorry biological sex gap because I can't
bridge 57 gaps not again for at least we
have far fewer tools at our disposal
men's true to cover up our shortcomings
can't wear makeup
high heels wigs think about that think
about that for a second well you're a
guy in high school if you're short and
you got bad skin you're just out of luck
you're just screwed you better hope the
puberty deals
and most of the time it doesn't yeah
women and by the way if you try to cover
up a zit if you put lifts you're caught
putting lifts in your shoes then all of
your male friends will file you in the
cabinet and the same drawers all those
gay male fashion designers they will
assume that if you put lips and your
shoes and use Clearasil cover up on your
zit that maybe just maybe you want to be
the next judge on project 1
that's a reasonably something hike is
another one I think we have some studies
here women have unrealistic expectations
of men as it relates to hi I'm okay with
the man you are taller
oh is this I figure about say I thought
you hit your light there to say so no I
didn't hit my lady just I said I'm okay
with this one because I was tall from a
very young age so I never had to deal
with it I just it's this is one of those
things where it's it's I think pissed
everybody off every man off at some
point we don't necessarily know why I
think it's because we know this to be
untrue women if you feel bad about how
you look you probably feel worse than
most men see you that's what you need
understand most men here every guy here
has a wife okay every guy here has a
wife who they love yeah they're all
attractive yeah they all look very very
different yeah the tall thin we have
some who are shorter we have some who
are curvier we have some who are thinner
we have some we're more athletic we
think that we all think they're
beautiful yeah I don't I don't know when
this started this idea that if we admire
someone who's beautiful and and no one
expects this in real life if you look at
a Jessica Alba or I don't know what Kate
Upton we can look at it and say that's
nice but this idea that men have been
putting pressure on their wives are
putting pressure on their significant
other to look that way I've never
experienced it I only see it in films
and the Entertainer you know what if you
if you worked out every now and then
maybe you could lose a couple of pounds
he's like the douche bag yeah redneck
husband I've never seen that in real
life yeah every time in real life you
know what happens woman drops are
closing the guy says I'm ready okay it's
a natural look I think women put an
unrealistic standard on other women yes
and it's so I I don't think that there
aren't men out there that do this I'm
course there are some douche bag guys
out there or stick expectations but
we're not talking about those guys we're
talking about the mainstream guys and
I'm telling you women you have these
standards for yourselves way more than
guys do my wife comes down
she says hey how do I look and I'm like
honey I'm a really bad person ask you
time right so a woman would be like oh
don't do this do this put this here do
that like she would critique it and in a
good way right but sometimes they just
tear each other down and that's not guys
putting the pressure on that's other
women right and the people who are
championing this lie by the way are the
people often perched a purse to top
their mountain from the one industry
where they actually do this was is the
entertainment industry in the media
they're the ones creating these stories
and these narratives these sexist ads
these unrealistic beauty centers okay go
down to your local paper mill for
Cronulla go down to your local I don't
know contract furniture company pick
some kind of a local business and see if
they are enforcing an unrealistic Beauty
standard upon woman the only place it
happens is in the entertainment industry
and Hollywood and the media and they are
the ones who bout it happening you know
they paid it off yeah this is what I'm
just rying to say women out their fat
pride is a bridge too far okay but if a
man is saying we're not that interested
in a land well whose blood type is
pudding
it doesn't mean that we expect you all
to look like Sienna Miller it's okay to
as long as you take care of yourself
you're within the boundaries of general
health most men find you attractive no
one expects you to look the way that you
think for some reason you're expected to
look and the people who want you to feel
that way are gay fashion designers and
bit B women who for some reason now have
some kind of a bully pulpit I say you
should take them out and then take your
husband out for a nice meal take your
clothes off because guess what he'll be
ready to go okay
sure change that's the magic of YouTube
and editing but if you did like this
segment on male and female body images
you might like this whole show that's
available at ladders CARICOM slash mud
clip we did a full review of the Joker
along with your letters that they like a
full hour of content if you don't want
to subscribe it letter of credit comm
slash mug Club which means that you're
okay with this show going away forever
because we've been demonetised for a
long time click one of these other
videos subscribe to the channel hit the
notification bell and if not then I
don't know you know I'm gonna I guess
thanks for stopping by but not really